National AIDS Day red ribbon
International AIDS Day is tomorrow of
course some of MP's work why did you
want to make that speech well there were
two main reasons one is that I was in my
constituency or nominating people for
awards for their bravery of speaking out
about their status and there seemed to
me a duty as a politician if I'm going
to be recognizing and congratulating
others for doing something to put your
money where your mouth is and I am
surely paid there's a politician to link
the personal with political messages do
you think that there is still a taboo
about telling people who are HIV
positive I mean was it was it difficult
for you yes it is difficult some of that
is internalized stigma you know kind of
the fear that you have yourself but some
of it is just that there is still a lack
of knowledge around how the treatment
means that you are you're undetectable
and you can't transmit the disease and
even sometimes the most well-meaning
people will kind of when I was writing
the speech and people looking over it
saying well hang on a second you can't
say that that's not true is it
I say well yes the NHS says it's true
you can't pass it on the NHS says that
this is the best way to stop the disease
is to treat people early so it is not
that people are hostile stigma but you
have that kind of friendly stigma that
people just don't know and the good news
as you pointed out is that for people
like you people live in this country
with the NHS people in the Western world
it is now a containable diseases that
it's not a death sentence I mean I have
to be hugely grateful for the NHS and
our health service to be able to rely on
that and so that I can then keep
contributing to society in whatever way
we have gone in the last few years
though globally made real achievements
22 million people around the world are
now on treatment we need another 15
million to go but if we meet that gap we
will be really serious to start that
then talking around abolishing HIV
entirely we managed to do it with small
pox we're almost managing to do with
polio I honestly think that the next
threshold is abolishing this disease
that only 30 years ago
we thought was a death sentence and
there was no wars wasn't it yeah I mean
is that where the focus needs to be now
away from the first world if I can put
it that or is there still work that
needs to be done by the NHS in this
country well there's still some work
needs to be done with NHS England we've
in a rather strange situation at the
moment that in Wales and in Scotland we
have this pill that you could take once
a day at the stops you're getting HIV
more effective than the condom a condom
with normal use you know people don't
use it perfectly as as a 70 percent kind
of rate of success that the pill we're
talking about almost a hundred percent
rate of success so in Scotland available
in Wales available the Northern Ireland
secretary here in Westminster who of
course is in charge of northerners has
made it freely available in Northern
Ireland with no camps but her
counterpart across the cabinet table in
the health secretary has not permitted
it to be freely available without caps
here in England adding that obviously
cost implications is quite as small so
it's not hugely expensive the generic is
coming out at the end of the year we're
talking about you know kind of 10 pounds
a pop in terms of kind of a monthly a
monthly container when the generics come
out and the NHS itself says over if prep
was introduced over the lifetime of the
next generation of people coming forward
it would say 1 billion for the NHS so it
is some initial inputs but there's a
long-term saving that the problem is
that the government has been slightly
too cautious let's put it like that to
be kind and they have introduced this
trial to try and see what the
behavioural changes will be but the
trial is now full and we know that there
are people trying to get this medication
in London who are unable to get it and
now are getting HIV and that to me is
unforgivable when we have the tools in
our hands to protect people in Britain
and we're able to protect them in
Scotland Northern Ireland and Wales but
for some reason England citizens are not
treated in the same manner and that is
quite easy for the minister to reverse
but the big push is needed overseas
we're in
Latin America places exactly I mean I
was in Africa because I sit on the
International Development Committee a
week and a half ago now and there we see
a stigma and Prejudice still rife I was
in the school where the children were
being taught that you could get HIV from
sharing towels and so there's still a
lot more that we need to re-educate what
is it there the question of getting the
same medicine it's about the medicines
but it's also about the information
because there's an you can provide all
the medicine but if you're not providing
the knowledge of how to properly use it
then you're you're on hiding to nothing
so some of that is about medicines
making sure that we pull global patterns
and so that we can actually leverage
more out for the same amount of money